Okay, okay, welcome everyone to
the DDPS seminar. Before we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and
logistics. First of all, please
mute yourself during the talk.
Unless you have questions. If
you have questions, you are
welcome to unmute and ask
otherwise, please use the chat
room to post your questions so
that you can address them in q&a
session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences. Therefore no
classified discussion is
allowed. So please watch help.
Finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now let me introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to
host RJ Harish who is an
Assistant Professor of
Engineering, simulation and data
science in the Department of
Mechanical, aerospace and Civil
Engineering at the University of
Manchester prior to arrival in
at Manchester as a was awarded a
bachelor's in mechanical
engineering from nitk surathkal
In India, a master's degree in
aeronautics from Caltech in us
and a doctorate in mechanical
engineering from Leibniz
University, Hannover in Germany,
and he was back in California
for the postdoc at the NH e ri
sim Center at UC Berkeley. His
research group at Manchester
develops numerical methods for
uncertainty quantification, or
application in modeling
waterborne Harders problems like
storm surges and tsunamis.
Today, they will talk more about
the uncertainty uncertainty
quantification and deep learning
for water hazard prediction. He
will be very interesting topics
so please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk. Now, without
further ado, let me pass the
baton to Jose by asking one
random question as usual.
Today's man the question, it's
not a random question. The same
questions we've been asking,
what is your favorite thing to
do other than research?
Especially in weekend? What do
you do in weekend?
Currently, I'm
spending weekends writing
grants, but I think I wouldn't
say that the most favorite thing
to do. I played a violin. So
that's kind of let's say
something that I would enjoy
doing. Oh, that's lovely. If I
get a little more time outside,
so
that's lovely. That's lovely.
Okay, stage is yours.
Thank Thanks, Jim. So thank you
so much for the introduction and
for the invite for the NDPs
seminar. Today, as you said,
I'll be talking about some ideas
about uncertainty
quantification, particularly
related to water hazards and
waterborne hazards like tsunamis
and storm surges. And anybody in
California is probably not new
to these events like so they
especially salami somebody on
the school definitely has heard
of storm surges. Especially
there's a recent Ida hurricane
there, which created quite a bit
of devastation away. So I'll try
to focus a little bit on the
physics of the problem as well,
just to highlight because not
everybody might be aware of how
these events are modeled, and
how are we looking at it? And
what are the different scales
and things like that. But before
I go ahead, I would just like to
just give a brief general
introduction about some of the
work that I've done in my
laptop. This is the overview of
today's talk. So what is the oh,
just overview of what we are
doing in our lab here in
Manchester. There's about nearly
SimCenter, a lot of work that
I'm talking today was done at UC
Berkeley, and I'm continuing on
that. And so this is one of the
directions we recently submitted
a grant to look at debris
loading of structures and so on.
And so what are these waterborne
hazards? And why are they
important, probably don't have
to stress on the why. What are
the modeling techniques? And the
answer to and how do we do
uncertainty quantification in
them. So it's a very high
dimensional problem, which makes
it really difficult to do
anything in here in a way. So I
actually go ahead and you will
see what's, what's the what are
the difficulties involved? And I
would certainly welcome more
ideas and I'm open to for
discussions in a way. So just to
give an idea of what we do in
our lab, there are two things
one is the application side of
things, looking at different
applications like storm surges,
tsunamis waterborne hazards,
fluid structure interaction
problem. At the moment, I'm also
looking at biomedical problem
related to neurovascular blood
flows. And on the other side, we
developed methods that can be
used in there are a lot of
methods already there. And how
do we improve these methods? How
do we make them better? How do
we especially look at code
coupling in a way, how do we
come A couple different methods
to look at their advantages. For
example, we are trying to couple
at the moment material point
method with finite volume
method. Material point does very
good with regard to large
deformations in structures. But
then it has lot of integration
issues, when you're looking at
flow problems for finite volume
does very well can be coupled
these methods to, let's say, do
more robustly. And of course, a
big part of it is uncertainty
quantification and machine
learning as well to accelerate
some of these simulations with
surrogate models and so on. So
once our application, the one
thing that we are looking at as
tribological applications, the
lot of emission standards out
there for exhaust emissions, are
they when they say exhaust
emission is it coming out of a
tailpipe, and especially with
the with the push for electric
vehicles, I think this is
something that's going to go
down. But what has not been
classified, like kind of
characterized well, is non
exhaust emissions. So this is
something related to tire wear,
and brake wear. I mean, it
doesn't appear like a very,
very, very, let's say, appealing
problem to look at him now, who
cares about the tires in a way,
right? I will, that's kind of
like somewhat the attitude if
there was a lot of industry as
well, as long as the tires lasts
for a while, we don't care. But
a big problem is all the two and
pm 2.5 particles and pm 10
particles, that's a significant
contributor to it. But then
there are no emission standards
that really regulate these kinds
of particle sizes coming out of
it. So that's kind of something
where we are looking at also we
do some bit of traditional
mechanics related to contact
mechanics, for example, a simple
result, just example of what we
what is called as the Flying
Spaghetti problems, I feel
spaghetti and just drop it down.
How is it going to like, you
know, fold around, and it's only
in a 2d problem in a way are
looking at contact mechanics
between very flexible bodies and
slender structures, or even 3d
contact, which kind of has
applications in tribology and so
on. I will tell you about it, if
you look at it, there's a lot of
uncertain parameters in there
right from the Roadster face to
the material model, but it's
extremely high dimensional
uncertainty quantification
problem that could look at. And
one of the recent applications
of ours have been to look at
data driven modeling in, in
looking at carotid and stroke
related issues, how do we
quantify the risk of a patient
for example, when a patient
comes in, they either come in
they have they look at it, they
say, okay, probably the patient
needs a surgical intervention,
or they go back and probably
they come back again, for
surgical intervention of the
it's pretty much late. So how do
we kind of say that, okay, this
patient has a higher risk for
stroke or somebody who does not
have a high risk for a stroke.
So there we are combining fluid
mechanics simulation with deep
learning techniques and Bayesian
neural networks. In order to
quantify the stroke width
between different patients and
predict some form of rescue, a
new thing that we started out
was to look at the cerebral
flows, especially regarding
neurodegenerative disorders. And
to look at the oxygen level in
one thing that we can easily
image is the larger capillaries.
But we cannot make a larger
arteries, but you cannot evade
the smaller capillaries and
veins. And one of the
difficulties that many of the,
let's say, very hard to do
automatically with a neural
network is to be able to
decipher between what's artery
what's a capillary and what's a
way away. So can we
automatically do use neural
networks to build these Wasco or
structure in our brain and look
at oxygen levels and eventually,
look at how the how these lack
of oxygen degrades the brain
tissue and so on. So there's
been a newly start work that the
new work that we started, it's
just just starting to work in
progress. But just to give you
an idea of it, apart from the
natural hazards, and one of the
other areas that I'm looking at
is biomedical problems where
there's a lot of uncertainty
quantification to think about.
Anyway, so just to start with a
lot of this work that I'm
talking today was done with an
area and Skill Center at UC
Berkeley. So just to give an
idea about them, because without
talking about them, this would
be I'll just do the
contributions that come from the
area from the sim center into
this work that we have done. So
there is a network of natural
hazards engineering research
infrastructure. So it has
several experimental facilities
for example, like there's a wall
of wind in University of
Florida, the large wave flume
facility in Oregon State
University and so on. There's an
earthquake in UC UC San Diego.
These are anything at least the
ones that I had interactions
with, and there are several
others are also experimental
facilities that contribute into
different natural hazards. And
SimCenter is what the police
station modeling and simulation
center where we were developing
or we are continue, we're
continuing to develop a lot of
computation infrastructure that
goes into these soft So as to
simulate natural hazards, and so
on. So the goal of the SIM
Center has been to build a very
modular open source framework.
So you can go to the GitHub, all
of this is available on GitHub,
all the work that we do. We have
built it in a very modular
fashion, for example, acid, how
do you characterize the assets?
For example, the building
infrastructure? How do you get
the information about that? How
to characterize the hazards like
tsunamis and storm surges,
earthquake, and we'll hazards
and so on? And how do you
eventually come out to the
response of it? You know, how do
we build a more resilient
infrastructure?
You know, of course, a
lot of a lot of this started
with looking at earthquake.
Center is currently in the
second phase of the funding from
NSF. In the first phase, a lot
of focus was on the initial
focus was on the US quake
engineering. So that's where a
lot of uncertainty
quantification also started
with. And eventually, this has
been adapted also for the
waterborne hazards and Windborne
hazards and so on. So what we
see here is essentially
a pointer. Okay, so
what we're seeing here there in
the red box here is what we call
confirm. And confirm
essentially, is the couple's
uncertainty quantification with
finite element. And eventually
all of your decisions on a
cloud, which is attack
supercomputer in Texas, and
hydro UQ essentially uses D.
Also users along with it brings
in tsunamis and storm surge,
inundation, and cod as well into
the fog. So the whole idea is to
combine earthquake, which is the
UQ, we use a wind, hydro, you
use the water and give a
probabilistic assessment through
PB n or today, so where people
can use that to build more
resilience based decision making
and so on. But today, we'll
focus on this one thing called
hydro UQ. And look at how these
waterborne hazards are firstly,
modeled. And second thing is,
what are the uncertainties that
come into these modeling these
events? And how do we account
for them in a way?
Okay. So
I think several of most of you
will be familiar with tsunamis,
a big one that happened was in
2004. When there was severe
damage to poles and coastline, a
lot of these damage happened
because of the debris. For
example, here on the bottom, we
can see the Indonesia coastline
before and after the tsunami on
the left side is before with a
lot of recovery, and so on. On
the right side is right after
the tsunami where everything has
been washed out. A lot of these
debris have to less than 10
meters per second speed. But
then they can be very, very
damaging when they kind of crash
into these into the building
infrastructure and so on. So the
tsunami basically killed about
250 1000 people. And so
magnitude of 9.2, we understand
the largest way was about 30
meters or about 100 feet when
the tsunami said and so that
eventually kind of washing away
literally anything on the track.
So one of the things that's very
important in these kinds of
events is to build vertical
evacuation structures that can
resist these kinds of floors,
with a horizontal evacuation in
these events is almost
impossible to think about. So
people try to do a horizontal
evacuation. And that doesn't
happen that kind of that
eventually leads to loss of life
and property. But then if we can
build large evacuation
structures that are vertical in
nature, that could probably save
a lot of lives. I mean, same
thing happened, for example,
these are ladies are 2010 Chile
tsunami, where there's again, a
lot of damage to the port, where
these shipping containers and
ships, as you can see, moved
into the Polish ships have very,
very small velocity at this
point. But eventually they have
a large mass. So they're
bringing in large amount of
momentum that can really destroy
these infrastructure. So it will
really, we want to make sure
that these infrastructures can
withstand the loads that are
there and they don't get damaged
in a way. That is one very
interesting event that we're not
interested in. But then very
important event that was missed
quite a bit during the 2011
Tohoku tsunami, where there was
supposedly two submarines inside
this port. And these two
submarines, when the when the
water the internet, through the
for the submarines were
basically rotating around there
as the water left through it, so
there is not there's not much
damage. So they did not come up
into the news. But there that
would be a very significant
important thing to account for
on where these ships and
submarines can be parked and how
to account for these kind of
hazard events and so on. of the
similar things happens during
the storm surges, for example,
this oil rig that happened in
2005, during Katrina storm
surge. And so you can see the
oil rig before and after the
significant amount of damage.
And this was a category five
hurricane, this was very similar
events happened with a hurricane
either recently in Mississippi,
where the river started flowing
backward for about two hours
from the Atlantic Ocean. So
instead of flowing into the
Atlantic, it was flowing out
back into the land for about two
hours. And then the flow was
restored. This was in the
Samsung, it's not just the water
waves, but also wind, that adds
an additional damage that can
create a lot of wind debris that
can really damage these
infrastructure and so on. So
essentially, we need to we got,
let's say, stop these events
from happening happening, but
then we need to build our
infrastructure that has that are
resilient. And that can account
for these kinds of events and
automatically saves that we need
to account for different range
of events, you know, it can be a
small event, it can be a large
event, but it can be once in 100
year event, but how do we
account for these things? And
that's where YouTube comes into
the picture, as you'd already
guessed, in a way. So just to
give an idea for what what,
what's the storm surge and how
does it happen? One can think
about that there's a center of
low pressure around with all the
waters being drawn. And as this
low pressure area moves towards
the land, this water is kind of
pushed towards land. So people
can expect about 15 to 20
meters, to 20 feet of storm tide
very easily. And again, this
depends on the magnitude of the
event, and the low pressure area
and so on. But you will during
storms are one of the biggest
thing and also the wind driven
surge, and also the wind driven
debris. And I made that kind of
comment along with the storm
surge, as well. So there's two
kinds of tsunamis as well, I'm
going back and forth between
storm surge and Salamis,
because, though the they are
different kinds of events,
eventually at the end of the
day, when it comes to modeling,
very similar approaches are
taken for both of these events.
And so as we'll see later on, if
we look at what colors are
tsunami, one or the other, like
you have a six week event, which
is an earthquake, so the motion
of the fall. So if roughly
crudely to think about you have
something of OSHA in Florida
suddenly moved up, which means a
whole block of water has moved
out. And now you suddenly this
this block of water has to go
somewhere, and it kind of moves
to work. And second thing is
landslide, which means they will
think of the that to be creating
a large magnitude tsunami. But
these are highly localized
tsunami and one of the largest
tsunamis where the or 400 meter
way was in Alaska, in 1958. So
these are very localized events.
But then this can create a lot
of damage in that particular
region, where there's a huge
landslide that's happening just
to just to look at some of the
modeling approaches. YouTube,
please tell please let me know
when, when I'm running out of
time, I will. Yeah, thank you.
So let's look at some of the
modeling approaches. Because
that kind of makes it important
to understand how do we put you
into the problem? What's the
problem in there before we can
put you to interpret right? So
just to most of you would have
done a video mechanic's course
and so I don't have to talk
about this wavelength, what's
the crest what's the trough or
the wave height and wavelength,
so right so, but then just to
get us all on the same page,
right. So, we have to crush and
distance between them is the
wavelength and distance between
the trough and the crust is
basically the wave height,
right. So, one of the things is
essentially what happens with
these kinds of events like
salami is a very long wave that
So, in the ocean, you in the
deep ocean, you will never
recognize that a tsunami is
coming in, because the
wavelengths are very long
compared to the compared to the
depth of the ocean floor. So,
but then only what what what
would happen is as these things
very crude image of what would
happen, as the wave moves
towards the shore, the depth of
the ocean floor is starting to
reduce, which means that this
energy that is coming in has to
go somewhere and height of the
way we went to Lincoln and that
is what what leads to a lot of
devastation in a way because as
soon as it starts to meet ocean
floor, the wheel starts to slow
down. And once it starts to slow
down, the faster moving wave
starts to crash starts breaking
away. Right. So crudely, to
think about this kind of leads
to a lot more devastation
because the wheel braking
effects and so on, that it says
a lot of interest to the
community. So the modeling
assumption that are often made
and one is the floor is
incomprehensible and reset. The
amplitude of the wave is much
larger, much smaller than the
wavelength and the depth of the
ocean. The flow moves or complex
documentary or topography so the
ocean floor is pretty complex.
And one of the things that
evolves over over multiple
scales, right, so in ocean, you
know, open ocean when you have
kilometer resolution, but then
when they come to the near the
coast, you need to look at a
meter resolution, as we'll see
some of the results later on,
you will see that we need
adaptive mesh refinement in
order to account for different
sets of grids that are there,
both in ocean flow to deep ocean
and in near the coast, you know,
like,
okay, so this is
what we did, we developed this
tool called hydro UQ that
combines the ideas of all the
brings to the, let's say, 3d
finite element 3d competition
fluid dynamics, where we use
open source tool, open foam. And
we brought in shallow water
solutions, as you will see later
on how all of these things are
combined. So but just to give
you an idea, so most of our
infrastructure is coastal
infrastructure, which is at
risk, for example, can be looked
at as these buildings that are
highlighted in this yellow
colored boxes. And so these are
our buildings of interest,
either it could be an offshore
structure, or it could be a
structure right on the coast.
And there could be either a
fault or a low pressure zone
that is driving the water. And
that will be our domain of
interest for our two day shallow
water solution. So if you want
to do a lot, if you want to do
CFD simulation or a large
domain, then you really need a
huge computation results. I, I
don't even know if it's
possible. I've never tried it
personally. But maybe people do
it for meteorology. People from
meteorology, do these kinds of
simulations. But in the most of
the communities, these waves are
more shallow water waves, the
shallow waters to the shallow
water solver is used in the deep
ocean. But as they come into the
coastline, you need a much more
high fidelity solution. Although
the shallow waters can capture
the inundation heights
reasonably well, they're not so
good at capturing the forces on
the structures, which is kind of
what you're looking at the
building response eventually.
And so there we combine this
with open foam on any kind of 3d
software. And the building
itself is looked at with a 3d
finite element and some
uncertainty quantification
looking at the building
response. At this point of time,
you are not interested in
looking at what is the let's
say, like uncertainty in the
event itself. But more like what
will be answered in it in a
structural response for a
particular event, eventually, so
eventually, that the idea will
be also to become combined to
like looking at uncertainty
between different sets of events
in a way. And that kind of that
makes it harder because the
looking at 3d CFD with
uncertainty quantification makes
it very time consuming. And
that's kind of where 3d FPGAs
really fast. So essentially,
coupling uncertainty
quantification with that as much
more easier and more
computationally efficient than
doing it with 3d CFD, fidelity,
CFD in a way. But just to give
an idea of depth right now, we
are slow. So we have basically,
Now historically equation, which
is our momentum conservation and
mass conservation. And what we
start by doing is looking at,
let's say, if we start to think
like, why are our components in
nature? Why is it that we start
to neglect that and when do we
start to look at it as a truly
problem, let's say on the clock,
No, we just start to look at it
as a warranty problem, that is
our depth from us exceeded our
walls direction in with the
waves propagating, then we can
reduce our lobbyists, dogs and
our mass conservation to do one
less equation there. And now
what we want to do is we want to
couple everything with with our
boundary conditions. So we have
a free surface, which we call
theta, and bottom surfaces B.
And we can say that, we can kind
of come couple our velocities,
we can say that our velocities
at the bottom surfaces maybe is
zero, and the pressure on the
top surface is zero,
essentially. So we use our
boundary conditions. And we, we
can, we can always generalize
this into Tuesday, we started
the week, and what we need to do
is we need to integrate all
right. So I've just chosen one
day One day in a way, but we can
always have the y component to
it, which will give you an
additional equation in there dou
u by dou x is nothing but in the
x direction and y direction
would be on the other side of
the direction of the surface
perpendicular to that and that
is our depth that we are looking
at. Primarily what we want to do
is we want to integrate all the
depth right. So, we are
integrating brings our bottom
surface or the ocean floor to
eat which is nothing but our
free surface. So once we are
able to integrate over from
bottom surface to the top
surface take on all of these
reducers into a much simpler
form, which is looking at how is
there variation of the height
with regard to time and what is
the variation of the say height
is essentially our bathymetry
they say the height of the water
column at that particular Time
is a particular point. And you
bar is nothing but the depth
average velocity at that
particular point at a particular
time. So both are a function of
x comma y and time. And he is
nothing but the word water
column, which is try changing,
as you'd expect, right. So, all
of these leads to a very nice
assumptions that that leaves us
with a 2d equation to solve on
the shallow waterfront in a way.
So again, we can always increase
that and we can write it in a
very nice form for our steady
state, where we can say our
steady state ocean is
represented by the hatches the
water column height, and B is
the location for bathymetry. So
we define a mean surface and
with regard to that, we can say
that is equal to zero. So zero
is our mean surface when the
ocean floor is your steady
state. So that kind that
accounts for let's say, any kind
of variation that will occur
that is that is there for the
water. Right. So I'll skip a
couple of equations here, but
probably can come back to that
as we as we progress through the
seminar and come back and have a
look at these equations in a
way. So, what what happens
during a tsunami initiation is
that we are just saying that our
freezer phase has changed by
some amount. So we say that it
was which is our freezer phase
is no longer at zero, we will no
longer at a steady state, but
the height of the eater which is
a freezer face has changed to
some amount and automatically
this DT r by dt progresses or
the entire set of equations
okay. So, all of this leads to a
very nice set of hyperbolic
equations on shallow water that
we need to solve. One of the
things that has to be done as we
need to discretize will be when
we take a 2d domain and we need
to discretize it, we have to
divide them as a COVID cell and
our DryCell. So that is what
makes it a little more
complicated. When cell is we
have some water or height or
water column is nonzero. And a
dry cell is where the height of
the water column is zero. So
because we are taking the
bathymetry of the ocean floor,
but we also are taking the
topography of the land overall.
And now as the water progresses,
it can move from one side to the
other in a discretized state,
where the where our mesh can
change from wet state to a dry
state and dry state to which
state so there can be a state
which are always wet, which
which are always dry. This is
the land and the word ocean
button, the coastal region would
always chain between the wet
state and the tri state and that
needs to be accounted for when
we're looking at the ocean. So
just to give you some examples
of the zone here, this
hypothetical magnitude seven
earthquake. So I wouldn't say
that squeak that happened or
something that would happen, but
this hypothetical case, so I
just want to be careful on that
on Alaska fault. So, where we
are looking at two points of
interest, one is the consent
city in California. And the
second one is Honolulu in Hawaii
and adaptive mesh refinement it
has been used from level one to
level six. So, this is what I
was saying that when we are
looking at a particular region,
let's say on the ocean, then we
are looking at a level one grid
which is very unrefined. And on
a when we are looking at some
kind of coastal region that you
need to refine this area, so
that you can get a much cleaner
and better resolution results on
the course where we are trying
to look at these events. So this
grid size, just to give you an
idea, one degree is about 110
kilometers, that is about the
grid size on the ocean in the
deep ocean that we are looking
at. And about the island we are
looking at near the coastal
region, we are looking at what
about half a second, where the
grid resolution is about 15
meters. So this will give you an
idea of the different grids that
are being used. And this order
case was run in collaboration
with Professor Patrick Linnet at
USC. So this was done when we
are well known UC Berkeley. And
the two regions of interest. One
is that place in Honolulu, and
one is a coastal region in
Crescent City in California. And
so this visualization of the
video progresses, what we are
looking at the red and blue is
essentially the trough and crest
of the tsunami wave that is
propagating in a way. So this
has been as we'll see later,
even though the scale is between
point two to minus point two two
plus point two meters. That is
because that's the let's say the
wave amplitude at Regis Honolulu
in Hawaii. But in in Crescent
City that's more than six meters
and we'll see in a couple of
minutes
from now. So as you'll see,
I don't know if fully observed
but probably something that we
can go back and again look at it
is if you look at this, this 110
kilometer grid as you'll see
that so the grid elects
extremely Oh, there are further
more cells in there. But then
there's just the outline so that
it doesn't look very bad. The
grid is extremely limited is
sparse in a way, it's not dense.
But as we, as the simulation
progresses, there's adaptive
mesh refinement, that that is
there in geo club. So most of
the simulations were done in geo
cloud, you can see here, the
Crescent City and again, near
Honolulu, in Hawaii, these
smaller groups are there. So
there's not exactly a level six
grid that you have seen, the
levels in sixth grade would be
much more dense in there. So
these have like the much more
smaller grids that are used near
the coastal region in order to
get a much more refined solution
and much higher accuracy with
regard to inundation depths, and
so on. So again, just just to
look at the level one grid for
the entire base, this is what we
were looking at. But that is
something that was imposed on
Google Maps. Again, we can see
that the different levels of
grids come into picture, and
then when the wave propagates in
there, so these cells are
essentially like a wet or dry
that I was showing in that
earlier, as a wet or dry kind of
changes. These are additional
grids that are there habitat by
geo Cloud automatically. So this
is a level six grid in the
Crescent City in there. Okay, so
usually, when you start this
level six grid is just one big
cell, it's not been there. But
now as the water flows in, you
can see that it really adapts
and to give a much better
solutions on all this is much
higher level grid, and you can
see all the different coastal
structures that are out there.
So as the water progresses in
these additional grids, or take
over it in order to give a much
better defined solution for
the problem.
Yeah, so there's again, like
Crescent City, where we can see,
there's basically a cross
sectional area of the Crescent
City that is there, where we are
looking at the water
progression. And we can see that
the there's one wave coming in,
so there's a second wave that
goes up to six meters. And the
third wave, it's about a little
more than two meters. But if we
go back to see that, so we can
see, looking at the water level
series, we saw that there was a
small wave coming in, and then
there's a wave that went up to
about six meters, and there was
a third wave that came in. So
it's not just one single wave
that comes in during the event,
but then there were multiple
views that could come in at
different levels. Again, if we
go back again to Honolulu to
look at it, we can see the same
kind of event in a way. But then
here the we saw the wave
amplitude was much smaller. And
that was a reason why the origin
video the wave amplitude was
capped at 0.2 meters. So you can
see everything is really red.
But there is so much of an event
here. I mean, like if you look
at the water level, there's
between about point two two plus
two point minus point two, two
plus point two meters in a way,
in Honolulu in about six meters
in the same city, California.
So, so these are the kinds of
modeling techniques that are
used during these simulations.
So we are looking at primarily
like shallow water simulations
in order to be able to get these
inundation depths. So first
thing is we get the inundation
depth. But second thing is what
do you do next with this
inundation? Absolutely. Right.
So we need to take these
inundation maps and somehow feed
it into CFD software. So what
happens here we have a 2d grid,
which is essentially a nice
square grid on our between a
certain latitude and longitude.
But now in a 3d simulation, you
have essentially like a face
that goes through the entire
ocean bottoms, ocean bathymetry,
in order to account for it. So
there needs to be somehow
conversion which, in some solid
mechanics sense, it's basically
like somebody's coming from a
solid mechanics background, one
can think of connecting a beam
or a plate to a shell or a beam
or a plate to like a solid in a
way. So you have a 3d object to
which you have 1d or 2d object
disconnected. So this is
essentially the same kind of
physics that needs to be
accounted for when we are
interpolating between a shallow
water solver into CFD. So in a
way, we have depth knowledge
velocity information, that needs
to be converted into full 3d
velocity to input into a CFD. So
Gary, hydro UQ does these
things. It takes the input from
the 2d or to shallow shallow
water solution that we were
discussing, and inputs it into
as a boundary condition into 3d
Open foam in order to run 3d CFD
simulations. So once these leads
3d CFD simulations have run, so
that gives us some forces and
borrow forces on our structures.
And that's where we want to we
had at that point of time, we
are focused to look at the
uncertainty quantification in
these structures. So a lot of
work also has to have to create
the summary and Akash was we did
a lot of work on the UQ methods
that have been developed. And
then they're still currently at
the same center where we're
working on the UQ methods. as
well. So where was what? What
did you want to look at? So
first thing is we wanted to look
at what is the propagation of
these uncertainties from inputs
to outputs, right? A simple
thing to think about is, let's
say we have some kind of origin
and design, but then there needs
to be an alternative design
because of the different
displacement that these designs
would lead to innovate, right.
So which design should we
select? So that's where
uncertainty quantification comes
in? And what are these buildings
structure? What are the
responses from these building
structures, looking at these
kinds of fluid loads that are
coming in? And particularly
looking at some of these debris
loads that are coming in as
well? Right.
So, so
two big things as, as I was
discussing with you, so right at
the start was one of the biggest
things, is this damage to
infrastructure? What is the
repair cost? And what is the
downtime? And that's one thing
that has been seen is the sludge
events significantly affect more
marginalized communities in a
way? And how do we make the
impact a little lesser? So we
want to understand the overall
uncertainties in our inputs? And
how do they are quality? How do
they lecture propagate through
the system in a way as outputs
and kind of looking at what will
be the repair cost or downtime?
Overall, in a way, right? So we
want to do all of these things.
And the simplest thing to start
out with is to say, Okay, what,
what would be the x modulus of
this structure to start with,
let's assume that this structure
is made of a steel structure,
what will be the NX modulus of
the structure. And if there's a
variation in its modulus, you
run a finite element simulation,
get the response of it. And so
to do some kind of forward
sampling, or to reliability
analysis to look at what would
be the significant damage and,
or even global sensitivity
analysis to look at the
importance of different
parameters that are there in
these structures, and so on. So
these are the kinds of things
that we wanted to eventually do.
And let's eventually be able to
make some kind of engineering
judgment. So most of the times,
it's, I would say, structural
engineers don't want to run a
CFD simulation that would take
15 days, or a week or so. And
but then if I talk to engineers
from the fluid mechanics side,
they're very happy now for 50. A
week is a normal CFD simulation
for many of them. But then for a
structural engineer designing a
structure, who wants they would
want quicker response. And so
kind of they want more, faster
problem faster solutions in that
kind of that kind of makes it
much harder to kind of bridge
both worlds in a way. But then
we want to somehow bring in
these things, and won't
understand this thing. And a
very straightforward approach
for us would have been to do
forward propagation. So we built
in the forward propagation
model, where somebody puts in a
different tank modelers run the
same, takes the same fluid load,
but is able to run the CFD
similar ran, the CFD solution
has a set of forces over time,
or time series of forces, and is
able to run the structural
simulation in order to get some
form of response. But then
again, a simple thing would be
to run off simple Monte Carlo.
But then we have, we also made
it a load things for them to run
Latin Hypercube, whether or even
surrogate models might
difficulty modeling in there to
make it more numerically less
expensive.
And so
again, second thing that we
wanted to do was to look at
reliability analysis. So one of
the things that is of interest
to a lot of natural hazards
engineer is to look at
reliability errors, and what
would happen if when would a
model, let's say, cross a
particular threshold. So I don't
care about you know, what, what
would be the loads on the
structure, what only I care
about if it went across a
particular threshold? If it
crosses a threshold, that's when
my structure would probably be
at risk to damage or to break or
to fail. And most of the
engineers structural engineers
won't understand that. I want to
reduce the number of simulations
in a way. For example, let's say
a 10%, would essentially mean
1000 simulations. The point
00 1%, would mean 10 parsecs
simulation in order to get that
kind that percentage of, let's
say, accuracy in a way. And that
that's where we are looking at
important sampling and subset
simulations. And so even
surrogate modeling and a
combination of both these kinds
of methods have been
incorporated into hydro UQ that
would allow the user to in order
to run their simulations, put a
structural model in there and be
able to do the reliability
analysis and make a decision
process have to look at
different graphs in particular.
The last couple of things that
are there in hydro refused one
is to look at global sensitivity
analysis. For example, if
there's Ulus, let's say or all
of these parameters equally
impacting response, for example,
there could be the models of the
beam that could be forces acting
on the structure, and it can be
variability in the structural
geometry itself in a way and how
do each of these different
variables in backbend which is
which has a high sensitivity and
which has a low sensitivity.
Look at so Sabol indexes and so
on. So hydro UQ makes it very
easy for a user. In order to put
these things in there and run,
they run their structural
simulations on the CFD channel
water and the structural
simulation to do a global
sensitivity analysis and very,
very straightforward manner. And
the last thing that is there is
looking at surrogate models
again, like here we have neural
neural networks and Gaussian
process that has been
incorporated into hydro UQ. And
something that we are working on
is to look at looking at design
of experiment to make it more
easily accessible to the user,
they can run these simulations,
and do some form of design of
experiments, including the CFD
as well. So that's kind of our
bottleneck in a way to see how
we can do faster CFD
simulations. Shallow water runs
very fast, but then the CFD is
the bottleneck to that high
fidelity in forces over time
series of forces in a very high
fidelity
manner. So since
people have been able to easily
build surrogate models, and we
are able to use that,
particularly on the structural
side, one parameter system, two
parameters system or even a
neural network in question
process, and so on. So one of
the last thing that we recently
have is looking at inverse UQ,
are by ation calibration. Were
looking at the students
simulation and looking at the
force time series forces on the
building's go back. And let's
upgrade the distribution after
the observing the data in a way.
So start with x modulus, but
based on your simulation data,
be able to update the models,
distribution, so that you're
able to calibrate for the kind
of structure kind of forces that
are that are there on the
structures and observe based on
observations and based on
whatever your simulation model
is gearing because there's a lot
of uncertainty in there, which
we don't know about structural
response itself. So again, like
this, this has been used to
calibrate material model,
reduced order model post even
damage diagnosis, especially
because there's a lot of image
that is available post event to
post disaster that can be used.
And can this be used to create
you can we will do by action
calibration in order to get the
structural response and how the
structure would behave if you
get such an event with the the
structures. So just did to date.
Hopefully, I'm still on time.
And now there's some time for
questions. All of these things
is available on the ad SimCenter
hydro UQ. So I will put the link
to the master one, where you
have the latest working version,
I would say. So there are other
beta versions that we are
working on. But so you can on
the near the same center on the
link, you can find it or you can
have software that will allow
you to do all of these
uncertainty quantification, but
not just use UQ. but also be
able to couple that with shallow
water and CFD and finite element
together. So that believe it
I'll leave this link with you.
And I will be happy to answer
any questions. Wonderful. Thank
you so much for the wonderful
talk. So let's have a q&a
sessions. So I don't see any
questions in the chat. Yeah. But
while you guys are thinking
about this questions, I can ask
some of the questions you said,
we use the neural net model for
the reduce reduce student,
whatever. So again, what sort of
the neural net model? Can you
elaborate a bit more on that?
Yeah. So so the hydro up has
both convolution neural networks
and RNNs in a way, because
there's a lot of time series
forecasting. So origins and LSDM
have, they're available. But
also, all of this is kind of
open source. So if a user wants
to bring in a different neural
network architecture, they can
add in when they can always push
in. So the idea is to make it
more common, more community
contribution in there. So one of
the recent things that is still
not available on Youtube is the
graph neural networks that we
use. So where we were trying to
build a surrogate model, not
just for the structural part of
it, but also for the shallow
water and CFD part of it, where
we use the graph neural network
in order to run some of these
CFD simulations and be able to
train that. And that's where we
will use also working with Latin
Hypercube method in order to
say, Okay, what should be our
next Tod simulation that we do
that would offer us record of
spend most of our space that we
would want to innovate? So we
combined Latin Hypercube method
to choose in the next set of pod
simulations. And all of these
was trained with the graph
neural network to create a
surrogate model. So there were
two outcomes coming out of this
one was basically a compression
in a way. So were wanting, I
mean, this was a side a side
effect of it, I would say. So
all of these simulations What
likely if you think of each
simulation like a Blu ray Disc,
and you put everything into a
pendrive? Right? So that's
that's essentially the idea that
we wanted to put in, can our
graph neural network, be trained
on lots of DCM CFD simulations
in order to be able to
replicate? Essentially, there's
a surrogate model. And that was
something that we were able to
do very successfully, you know,
woods for cod or for the shallow
water solutions. And second
thing that we were able to do
was, is not just you not just
train it as a surrogate. But
then now, can you, for example,
one of the biggest things for a
lot of users on high HPC
systems, when you are working
with hundreds of processors, it
will download this data. I mean,
a very, very crude mesh here
gave about a 300 gigabytes of
data. That's a very crude, but a
bad simulation, I would say. So
we were talking about terabytes
of data in a simulation. And
nobody wants to really download
that to do the post processing
and things like that. Especially
for to create visualization. So
what we did was to train the
graph neural network with our
simulations. And then you could
download your graph neural
network, still the network and
just download that. And you
could train it a different
accuracy. For example, let's say
for visualizing, I don't need to
have 100% accuracy, I don't need
a six decimal digit, a second
decimal digit is sufficient for
my visualization. So we were
able to almost get 1000 times
compression, because you know,
so you say, Okay, I need a 90%
accuracy, which doesn't give me
a six decimal digit, but just a
fraction, decimal digit. And
that pretty much gave you almost
1000 times, let's say
compression in a way. And you
could just download that and use
it for visualization purposes.
So this was, this is not yet put
into IOU, but this is the next
thing that will hopefully go in
in the next couple of months.
Just curious, I mean, the graph
neural network training of the
Google graph, neural network can
be very demanding. And you said
that Ada is probably training
itself, it will be pretty
computationally demanding. But
you put all the efforts, you
know, I had and then, you know,
make it available to the public.
So
what we did was to create a sub
process. So as a CFD simulation
is running every once it
finishes every step, it there's
also sub process that is running
parallel process that is running
with it, which is running the
graph neural networks, that
sends a message to the graph
neural network and saying that
there's a new result available,
and use that to kind of do the
batch training with it. So each,
each measure itself is quite
big. So each time step is broken
into much smaller batches to do
the training in a way. And
there's also a bit of domain
decomposition in there, to not
just claim it as one single
domain, but as multiple domains.
So that when you can, before a
CFD simulation runs,
complete,
your your training your graph
neural network, but then you're
done quite a bit of it already.
And you don't have to train
every single time step.
Sometimes. We kind of try to
adaptively, see if it can
extrapolate and check for the
error with the solution. And
based on the error, it doesn't
have to train that particular
time step but can skip the time
step and go ahead. So that way,
you can save some time as
ice. So basically, you guys do
this some storage apps for us,
and then the users can take the
data from the graph neural
network.
Right? Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Exactly. So yeah. So basically,
the idea is essentially to make
it make HPC systems easily
usable for users. So they don't
have to download all the data.
Because Because this tool runs
on the Texas Advanced Computing
Center. And so somebody who's
never used the HPC system can
still use it, because there's a
nice interface use it. So they
just give somebody a button and
everything job submits there
through an API. But then like
when the ones they say download,
and now this is starting to
download everything that could
be contained for the user to use
it. Right? So then they don't
want to really use that. So it
tries to download minimum amount
of data because everything what
happens is all the simulation
data is now transferred to
design says they can go to this
design safe portal and from
there, access their account and
get all the data from the
simulation. So it's a bit old's
way of doing things I would say
but without criticizing that. So
this the whole design save works
is basically transport one file
at a time from the tax system. I
don't know why didn't build it,
but somebody else had built it.
So which kind of really slows
down when you have a lot of
files in a way. So you want to
download everything as one
single punch, you know, and that
kind of downloading a single
neural network and repackaging
it makes it much more easier.
Okay, sounds good. Okay, so
during during the, you mentioned
the lighting and procure for the
sampling to fire out to sample
next time, Latin Hypercube is
the predefined the design of the
choice methods, so, but there
are there is a physics space,
it's based sampling, which can
tell you where the maximum error
is in terms of the physics and
then you can use information to
determine the where the next
sample would be. So that might
give you a better better way of
sampling than simply using a
predefined. hypercube. Okay, so
any other feedback? Yeah.
Any other questions? Sergey, and
Sergey has his hand raised, I
think.
Oh, yeah. Okay. Yeah. Please
unmute yourself. And then
Sergey, you're welcome to unmute
yourself. Thank you for very
interesting presentation. I have
kind of a strange question. Like
information reducer seems to be
very important. What you're
doing so just wanted to give
this to city planners.
Lawyers, which are like making
decisions, like financing stuff
by building this vertical?
Line, Excel is I don't know how
to say about predictions of
Escalade. It can be stimulated
the use cetera. But not I find
striking, nice light about
notions from cars and jets.
correctly, pollutions exhaust
the fact that this is an island,
she was kind of striking. So
Jeff, I'm asking what you're
doing. So both your eyes to
data.
I also see is that like, using
this kind of simulation or not?
Making people to think again,
what factors are involved. And
in many cases, before, there was
no clear models to take the
stock first and take off. Now
you can do it even, like reserve
goods, physical model. And as is
quite important to you analyze
all existing models and factors.
That's fine meeting factors.
What you're doing about like to
popularize this idea for this
question.
Now, I broke up a little bit in
the middle. You also were able
to catch all the questions, and
you have a lot of interesting
data important data for people
that are lawyers, or city
planners, etc. Because you're
going to prefer to make them
known to public twice public.
Okay, yeah. So
I think she'll Center has its
own way of publicizing things.
Now, I'm not officially with the
sim center. So one thing that
I'm doing also in the UK at the
moment is trying to work with
some of the city council here in
Manchester in the UK. And also
there's a consortium called CCP
WSI plus. So it's called the
computational center for wave
structure interaction. So where
we also looking at the tsunamis
and storm surges and these
events, and we are trying to
work with, let's say, so one of
the industries that we are
looking at is to look at if this
would be interesting to
insurance industries, especially
those who are doing like
reinsurance and looking at
insurance in hazard areas,
particularly that could help
them really make a better
assessment of what what are the
events that could happen in
here? What is the real risk that
is there, that could really
reduce some of the premiums that
are being charged in a way so we
are trying to work with some of
the insurance companies and also
with City Council's and city
planners to see how we can bring
these tools into their design
process and to into their
decision making process. But the
difficulty is that it it's a
it's quite hard because
eventually there's a lot of
there's a lot of uncertainties
in the system. So that kind of
makes it really harder for them
to reset take a decision based
on these tools. But there's a
very concerted effort trying to
get it to them in a way and
trying to get them to do it. So
one of the recent things that I
myself started was to look at
debris. For example, UK recently
released the report that said
that we don't really have any
kind of database of what could
be the debris that happens
during comes during these
flooding events. So most of the
damage that happens is not just
because of the water, but we
sample there's, let's assume
there's a car that is floating
in, and that blocks a building.
Now the water that has flowed is
not able to flow past the car,
so kind of the water level
builds up a little bit around
there, and now that are both
loading onto the structures in a
way. So we don't really have a
lecture database that says, This
is the kind of event that
happens, these are the kinds of
debriefs that are coming in, and
so on, so forth. So we're trying
to build, let's use YouTube
videos and post hassled videos
to do object detection to map
out what are the kinds of
events? And what are the kinds
of debris that would come in
because of these events? And how
do we use that in our physical
simulation, to not just look at
this way, but also to look at
the breeze. So that would give
us a much more or less a more
robust, let's say, evaluation of
the structural response in way
more, in a way, so that there's
not a concerted effort going to
get this into the hands of the
city planners and structural
engineers. And also,
particularly with regard to also
insurance companies and so on.
But the progress is, I would say
reasonably slower than what we
would like. We would of course,
like them to immediately
integrate into their design
philosophies. But I think that
takes more time. I think that we
need a more concerted effort
there.
Yeah. Yes, thank you. Thank you
very much. I understand what
you're doing. is interesting,
for example, tell companies
scientists were doing the old
climate prediction model. Right,
is to be quite accurate. And,
nevertheless, company was doing
what they were doing. They were
doing the same stuff. And as
you're making the product, which
insurance company you can make,
and I can rephrase my question,
Are you considering to, like
brains, this information to
actually click with activities?
Not only to companies? Yeah,
they can affect government and
companies. Yeah.
Because Because the problem is
extremely multifaceted,
multidisciplinary. Also, we try
to reach out to the geophysicist
and climate scientists and
people who are in the, let's
say, Geo, geological area, you
know, a kind of niche, I would
say, who are looking at more
like the things like
sedimentation, erosion, and all
of these things as well and
climate change what sea level
rise as well, to see how this
can also be incorporated
incorporated into their
workflow. Biggest problem is
some of these simulations that
we do are very local innovate,
right? So even though we can do
a large scale simulation, they
were more focused on building
your like Alexei 10s of
buildings, or, for example, a
critical infrastructure, maybe a
nuclear or chemical plant or
something like that, which is
around the corner. So it's more
local, than looking at the
global infrastructure itself. So
so this skill we're doing
reaching out to them, but then I
think they are looking at a
different scales. So there's
still a bit of a mismatch in
discussion. So So one of the
biggest things that we are
trying to do is firstly, to
reach out to, let's say,
academics and faculty, even in
the humanities area, because
they look at the post disaster
event how, how do communities,
let's say, How is the damage
changing? After after the damage
happened? How do communities
come back to normalcy? I would
say, I'm not getting that word.
But let's say that they have a
disaster. They're all displaced.
Now they have to come back to
their homes. And how much time
does it take for these things.
So even this is, this would be
our very first step to see if we
can make the change there. So
that this, this amount of time
that people need in order to
come back to their homes can be
reduced. So if you can really
say take a community and prevent
the kinds of damage that could
happen, depending on the events,
can you improve the resilience
of the community? Can we make it
better, so that they are less
affected over time because of
these events and so on. But then
yes, this is an effort to reach
out to climate scientists and
those who are modeling sea level
change. But I think then we need
to start communicating in the
same language. I think the
border communities need to start
Talking in the same language. I
think that's there's a bit of a
mismatch at the moment.
All right, that sounds good.
Okay. If if, Sergei, if you have
a more questions,
thank you very much.
I guess you can ask to, you
know, send an email and then the
Ozzy will be happy to answer.
Yeah. Yeah, there's a another
question by Jeremy. And he
asked, you mentioned the
building a digital twin for
adding aiding in making decision
is your twin comprised of the
surrogate or the for the model.
That is, is the intent of the
twin to be used in real time is
the twin and the decision making
with a twin aware of the
uncertainty you are quantifying?
Those other questions?
So the idea of building these
digital twin is essentially
comprised of both the surrogate
model and also based on the
actual, full, full full fidelity
simulations. We essentially, I
forgot where I put that, but
then we essentially don't want
to just limited to the surrogate
model, but then we also want to
have fulfilling. On the
structural side, we don't have
much of a problem with running a
full fidelity because most of
the structural models are made
of beams and plates and
structural elements, which run
reasonably fast. For example,
you can learn how to collect
each simulation probably takes a
few seconds, maybe at most, a
very complex building simulation
might might take a little
longer. But we can run a full
fidelity simulation, we don't
necessarily need a surrogate
model. But having a surrogate
model allows us to span a whole
bunch of space and makes it much
easier to look at it in a way so
the you can you can run either
both a surrogate model or full
fidelity model.
Okay, sounds good. Okay.
Next question is by oven. Oh,
well, no, it was not a question.
It was this. It was thanking you
for the great. Okay. Is there
any other questions? From
audience? No. Okay. Let's Well,
then let's thank our speaker as
a today for the wonderful talk.
And if you have a, you know, the
additional questions, please
email as a directly, I think he
will be happy to answer you. And
also if there is any
collaboration opportunity. Yeah,
please reach out to it. Yeah.
So, as a you're looking for
collaboration, right?
Definitely, definitely. You
served out very happy if anybody
has any questions or would be
interested in collaborating,
then there's a lot of
opportunities in this area.
There's a lot of open problems,
and I would be very, very
interested. You can also look,
the My Lab website at Idi
lab.co.uk. And you can also find
my email there. Also, I think
this email is maybe there on the
invite, and I will be very happy
to work with you as well and if
you're interested.
Wonderful. Well, thank you.
Thank you so much for the
opportunity. Thank you.
So thank you so much. Bye bye